[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 nous sommes le jeudi 7
juin tout de suite les titres de cette
édition l'événement a réuni les acteurs
majeurs de la mobilité de l'automobile
l'imaginent mobility forum se tenait
aujourd'hui sur le campus de l'estac à
montigny le bretonneux 300
professionnels et experts présents à ce
rendez vous de l'innovation proposée par
le pôle movéo c'était le premier du
genre à saint quentin en yvelines le
salon santé et bien-être a réuni plus de
500 visiteurs à la ferme du manège
stands conférences animations et une
signature également pour terminer la
journée celle du deuxième contrat local
de santé du territoire
et puis elle souffle cette année sa 40e
gougy la résidence jean fourcassa de
trappes accueille des personnes âgées
autonomes
un lieu qui vous le verrez a évolué
depuis sa création en 1968 dans ce
journal deux invités également à suivre
benjamin hayes cronin président de
l'école de la deuxième chance du val
d'oise
elle a repris en gestion récemment son
homologue des yvelines et puis olivier
jeunes ex responsable du centre
d'information europe direct c'est à
saint germain en laye après une nouvelle
journée de mobilisation ce jeudi la
grève des cheminots se poursuit demain à
la sncf
vos prévisions si vous partez où
arrivait dans l'une des gares de saint
quentin en yvelines
elles sont habituelles en ce moment
trafic réduit de moitié c'est un train
sur deux pour le rer c les lignes n ai
eu du transilien anticiper un maximum
vos trajets les horaires de vos trains
sont à consulter sur le site
transilien.com le campus de l'estaca à
montigny le bretonneux accueillait toute
la journée le forum imagine mobility
l'événement annuel du pôle mov'eo et qui
rassemble près de 300 acteurs des
filières de l'automobile et du transport
avec comme thématique les innovations et
la mobilité du futur nicolas d'ambri et
clémence tergnier
donc le principe c'est le robot me suit
et porte la charge à ma place puisque
donc dans le robot je suis capable
d'installer ce que je veux capable de
porter des charges de plus de 40 kilos
ces robots collaboratifs sont utilisés
pour faciliter les déplacements dans les
usines des produits vendus notamment
dans le secteur automobile et
aéronautique
une fois qu'il a repéré son
environnement il devient autonome
c'est-à-dire qu'il âgées plus cette
télécommande et le robot il suffit sur
une carte sur un smartphone en fait du
programme destination et le robot va et
où seuls à cette destination des
équipements présentés dans ce forum
imagine mobility sur le campus de
l'estac a organisé par le pôle de
compétitivité movéo cette structure veut
faciliter les échanges entre les grandes
entreprises les pme et les collectivités
on se rend compte aujourd'hui que pour
innover la puissance d'un grand groupe
donne des moyens mais l'agilité des
start up des pme
épousant le démontrer c'est ça qui crée
souvent l'élan pour innover nous
aujourd'hui investir pour la mobilité
c'est investir j'irai dans l'avenir de
notre département parce que c'est ce qui
fera l'attractivité de notre territoire
parce que sans mobilité sans transport
un territoire n'est rien donc la
mobilité c'est ce qui va compter ce qui
va nous permettre aujourd'hui de prévoir
de prévoir notre territoire de demain de
prévoir aussi tout son développement
économique
les laboratoires représenté aussi lors
de cette journée des doctorants de
l'estaca ont présenté leurs travaux
énergie propre véhicule autonome qualité
de l'air des thématiques de recherche
on s'inspire de son tous les cas de ces
problématiques là pour donner des
projets ad
faire contribuer les étudiants estaca à
l'aboutissement de deux shorts de ce
genre de projet une dizaine de projets
de recherche collaboratifs menée par des
étudiants de l'estaca ont reçu le label
movéo l'actualité en bref peut-être le
début d'une pénurie la fdsea et les
jeunes agriculteurs vont bloquer des
raffineries et dépôts de carburants à
partir de dimanche 13 sites à travers la
france dont celui de coignières sont
concernés une action pour protester
contre la politique agricole du
gouvernement et de la commission
européenne notamment sur les
importations d'huile de palme
concurrence est déloyale selon les
exploitants face aux productions
françaises et de colza et de tournesol
le blocage des raffineries et dépôts
devrait durer jusqu'au être 13 juin au
moins ils sont des dizaines concernées
dans le département des candidats au
permis de conduire se retrouve
aujourd'hui dans l'incapacité de
poursuivre leur formation pourtant en
payer cette auto-école yvelinois ce qui
dépendent de trois entreprises
différentes ont été placées en
liquidation judiciaire fin mai à
certaines ont tout de même continué à
encaisser des inscriptions est les
candidats lésés doivent se rendre à
versailles pour récupérer leurs dossiers
auprès du mandataire judiciaire
ils ont la possibilité de déposer une
plainte auprès du tribunal de grande
instance ou de saisir le juge civil pour
un éventuel remboursement du changement
du côté de l'école de la deuxième chance
des yvelines depuis el début même elle a
été reprise en gestion par son homologue
du val d'oise bonsoir benjamin cros un
bon soir vous êtes le président de cette
école de la deuxième chance dorénavant
qui s'étend sur le territoire des
yvelines et du val d'oise alors cette
reprise en gestion était finalement
effectué pour des raisons financières et
ce que l'école de la deuxième chance des
yvelines était menacée de disparition a
été menacé à deux titres d'une part
le bureau de l'école avait démissionné
donc l'école depuis début mars n'avait
plus de président de trésorier et c'est
ce qui met en péril sa gestion
quotidienne et avaient du mal à boucler
son budget pour l'année 2018 donc les
financeurs sur le département la région
la préfecture sont venus par moins pour
essayer de trouver une solution est donc
en moi on a créé un modèle où on va
mutualiser des fonctions supports cire
le directeur général le la times
financières etc
pour donner un nouvel élan à l'école
alors il ya une solution de
réorganisation bien sûr mais aussi de
nouveaux projets qu'on va lancer dès
maintenant on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler juste après pourquoi fallait-il
la sauver cette école de la deuxième
chance des yvelines parce que c'est un
outil formidable des écoles deuxième
chance pour résumer c'est vous avez
entre 18 25 ans vous n'êtes pas diplôme
pas de formation mais vous avez un truc
devait envie de d'avoir un projet
professionnel et nous on va vous
accompagner pour ce projet professionnel
on va vous aider à le développer vous
aider à vous former et vous trouverez
une entreprise c'est des jeunes qui sont
à moitié en formation moitié à l'école
sa roseraie sur l'alternance avec des
stages en entreprise fait ce sont des
jeunes qui sont des stagiaires de la
formation professionnelle celles qui
sont rémunérés le temps qu'ils sont qui
sont à l'école et nous notre but c'est
un peu de faire éclore leurs projets
comme on dit souvent dans nos quartiers
on a des pépites il faut un peu
les aider à éclore c'est notre métier ce
sont des jeunes qui ont parfois perdu
confiance en eux aussi ils ont perdu
confiance en eux ils ont perdu confiance
en systèmes e
éducatif ils ont fait un peu tous les
dispositifs sans vraiment trouver leur
voie et nous on va les aider à trouver
leur voie
avant de parler de ses projets dont vous
nous disiez deux mots il ya un instant
est ce que ça qu'est ce que ça change
concrètement d'avoir une école
maintenant avec un territoire plus
étendue sur le val d'oise et sur les
yvelines ça crée des synergies
ça permet aux jeunes de conflans d'aller
à cergy
plus facilement puisque c'est la même
structure aujourd'hui et
ça va créer plus de mobilité auprès des
jeunes puisqu'ils vont pouvoir aller
d'un département à l'autre
et puis ça nous permet aussi d'avoir des
projets d'envergure plus importants
qu'on pouvait pas faire cela avant
d'accord mais comme maintenant à pourra
faire trois sites
exit existe aujourd'hui sur le
département des yvelines
aux mureaux à magnanville et attrapes
est ce que votre stratégie c'est de
conserver ses trois sites peut être
réorganisé la carte de vaud implantation
sur le territoire alors l'idée ces deux
bêtes les sites à côté des transports au
coeur de ville donc là en train de
discuter avec pas mal d'acteurs sur les
collectivités
hammerson par exemple pour le centre
commercial qui n'est pas loin d'ici
pour réimplanter les écoles je donne un
exemple aujourd'hui à cergy-pontoise
l'école et dans le centre commercial des
trois fontaines ça nous permet derrière
de fer des boutiques école c'est que des
boutiques nous on gère avec nos jeunes
c'est de la formation pratique et pas
théorique et ça permet à nos jeunes de
se faire débaucher par des boutiques d'à
côté pour trouver dans ces 10 personnes
qui est propriétaire notamment l'espace
saint quentin centre commercial à
montigny le bretonneux vous lisez une
formation basé sur l'alternance combien
de temps va durer la formation de ces
jeunes alors centre 6 cellules nous le
but c'est qu'ils trouvent une formation
ou un boulot plus rapidement possible
donc nous on les suit entre six mois et
après il ya un an de postes suis sûr que
une fois qu'il a entreprise
on va encore le suivre pour accompagner
pour voir si c'est pas difficultés avec
le chef d'entreprise
donc c'est 6 à 8 mois dans les codes et
avant de postuler
du côté des yvelines 400 jeunes passent
chaque année par l'école de la deuxième
chance le taux de sorties positives donc
avec un emploi ou une formation à la fin
de ce cursus est de 60 % actuellement
quels sont vos objectifs cessé
d'augmenter j'aurais juste dans le val
d'oise 73%
c'est d'arriver au minium 1 73% et de
tirer des deux écoles vers le haut pour
ça on va mettre en place dès la rentrée
des modules métier ça qu'on va faire des
coups fils donc les jeunes on va les
amener vers des métiers exemple le
numérique la fibre d'installation fillon
trente mille emplois par an soit 1 500
de fibre en france donc il ya deux il ya
du boulot
et puis en plus on va mettre en place
c'est ça ça rebondit sur votre reportage
avant tout nos jeunes à partir de
maintenant vous passez de code
gratuitement dans notre école sera dans
leur formation et on va lancer un test à
la rentrée pour le permis de conduire
avec un tiers financement par le jeune
un tiers en test avec la région et un
tiers j'espère avec le département où
d'autres l'utilité qui puisse nous aider
ce sera un permis en intensif on a
réussi à développer à 700 euros
vous parliez du numérique aujourd'hui de
se positionner sur ce secteur c'est
primordial c'est des métiers qui vont
embaucher qui embauchent déjà mais qui
vont embaucher de plus en plus l'avenir
c'est mythique embauche de plus en plus
nos jeunes n'y sont
malin intelligent il arrive nous on va
monter et on va demander de la belle est
en train de le faire pour les yvelines
une grande école du numérique
dans les yvelines avec les connaissances
des villes où là on va avoir tout ce qui
est programmation installations de
fibres pilotage de drones etc
l'école de la deuxième chance deuxième
chance pardon vous l'avez dit concerne
les 18 25 ans est ce que l'idée c'est
aussi peut-être de regarder plus jeunes
la tranche d'âge adolescente par exemple
tout à fait on lance on a répondu aux
appels à projets de la région et des
différentes collectivités
on va faire un sas on appelle ça les
décrocheurs donc à partir de 16 ans et
on pourra peut-être descendre sur un
appel à projets jusqu'à 14 ans où là on
va les accompagner
soit un retour vers la première chance
air l'éducation soit vers un cfc pro
soit venir à l'école deuxième chance
parce qu'ils ont besoin de créer un
projet professionnel mais on va faire
tomber cette digue du majeur mineurs dès
la rentrée prochaine
ces élèves qui sont parfois en
décrochage scolaire c'est important
d'intervenir aux plus jeunes dès l'âge
de 14 ans par exemple tout à fait et
nous on aime particularité c'est qu'on
l'intérieur saïd et pédago c'est pas des
pédagogues qui vont intervenir nous
c'est des commerciaux parce que souvent
ils ont en marre des cours etc
c'est pas ça qui leur font leur faut ce
qui leur faut c'est un peu de coaching
et ça des gens qui ont fait du commerce
qui on est et commerciales sont très
bons pour ça et c'est pour ça qu'en face
d'eux on va mettre des commerciaux et
pour retrouver toutes les informations
sur l'école de la deuxième chance
d'éliminer du val d'oise vous pouvez
vous rendre sur le site internet à qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran merci
benjamin je croyais avoir été avec nos
présidents de cette école de la deuxième
chance du val d'oise et des yvelines
une quarantaine de professionnels et
associations réunis hier mercredi le
premier salon de la santé du bien-être
de saint quentin en yvelines étaient au
programme
un événement mise en place par
l'institut de promotion de la santé 500
personnes ont fait le déplacement à la
ferme du manet de montigny le bretonneux
reportage de camille lambert et toki
nirhy lanto à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
+2 50% des médecins généralistes vont
partir à la retraite dans les prochaines
années pour pallier la désertification
médicale sur son territoire
l'agglomération a signé son deuxième
contrat local de santé avec ses
partenaires notamment l' agence
régionale de santé et la préfecture des
yvelines travailler vraiment l'offre de
soins
former des médecins faire en sorte que
des médecins qui les jeunes médecins les
étudiants en médecine de l'université
qu'ils puissent rester sur le territoire
qu'ils puissent exercer sur le
territoire il ya une centaine de
professionnels de santé qui va falloir
faire venir sur le territoire dans les
cinq 5 à 7 ans à venir
une signature qui se tenait à l'occasion
du premier salon du bien être organisée
par l'agglomération
une quarantaine d'exposants étaient
présents à la ferme du manet comme cette
maison des géants pour prévenir les
risques domestiques ou cet atelier pour
réaliser son propre dentifrice large il
aurait voir mettre un petit peu et j'en
mettais beaucoup argile blanche de
carbonate de soude quelques gouttes
d'huiles essentielles et un peu d'eau
des ingrédients naturels
on utilise tous au quotidien que ce soit
savon shampoing maquillage dentifrice
brasser des produits concise au
quotidien et idc d'essayer de creuser un
peu
voilà on les utilise mais qu'est-ce qui
a concrètement à l'intérieur développer
la connaissance sur
les domaines de la prévention pour les
enfants pour les sensibiliser
sensibilisés à l'environnement et puis
la santé très important selon
l'organisation mondiale de la santé la
plupart des maladies chroniques comme le
diabète ou certains cancers seraient
directement liées à nos modes de vie
pour sa première édition ce salon a
attiré plus de 500 visiteurs
vous allez développer cette année en
france une action ou un événement sur
l'union européenne et bien sachez qu'il
est possible d'être aidés financièrement
la représentation en france de la
commission européenne a lancé un appel à
propositions pour identifier et soutenir
ces projets on en parle tout de suite
avec notre deuxième invité olivier
jeanne drecq ce bon soir qu en soit l
vous êtes le responsable du centre
d'information europe direct il est situé
à saint germain en laye alors avant
qu'on présente cet appel à propositions
ce programme dead qu'est ce qu'un centre
d'information europe direct donc les
centres d'information europe direct ce
sont des relais d'information locaux qui
ont été mis en place par la commission
européenne parce qu'elle s'est rendue
compte qu au fil des différentes études
qu'elle a menées que les gens savaient
peu de choses sur l'union européenne et
donc elle a justement décidé de remédier
à ces à ce problème en mettant justement
en place des ces lieux dès qu'ils soient
en fait donc hébergé par différentes
structures donc dans les yvelines le
seuil de à saint germain en laye est
hébergé par la maison de l'europe des
yvelines l'idée c'est d'être un
véritable relais local finalement de la
commission européenne sur un territoire
comme les i mean exactement la plupart
de la plupart du temps quand les gens
entendent parler d'europe ils se disent
oui c'est loin c'est bruxelles et ainsi
de suite alors que nous on en fait il ya
bon en fonction du département et en
fonction du lieu où on se trouve il ya
parfois il ya une structure à proximité
et on va dire qu'il ya juste à ouvrir la
porte d'entrée pour pouvoir
pour pouvoir obtenir des renseignements
que ce soit par exemple sur comment on
fait ses études à l'étranger pour
connaître ses droits de citoyen repères
et ainsi de suite et qu'elle trouve
omission justement c'est il ya cette
mission d'information est ce qu'il y en
a d'autres missions alors au niveau de
nos hôtes
alors oui principalement on a cette
mission d'information alors après
moi au niveau des activités j'ai
d'autres activités dans le cadre de la
maison de l'europe
je participe par exemple j'anime des
animations ça peut être à destination
des jeunes tandis qu à part à
destination des jeunes en collège ou
lycée
ça peut être aussi animer des ateliers
qu'on fait par exemple pour les
demandeurs d'emploi donc voilà c'est le
domaine associatif on al'avantage
d'avoir une gamme d'activités qui est
assez vaste et aussi informé du coup
vous le disiez sur des programmes
existants comme on va on va le présenter
dans un instant voilà informés les
yvelinois sur les différents programmes
européens qui peuvent exister exactement
parce que la plupart du temps les
programmes européens sont ouverts à
beaucoup de monde et
la formation on va dire est un peu un
peu difficile d'accès parce que c'est
souvent rédigés selon du jargon européen
et il faut toujours une personne qui
soit là pour pouvoir qu'ils soient là
pour pouvoir justement traduire en
termes compréhension malgré un public et
aux aujourd'hui c'est mon rôle
d'accord alors on appelle la proposition
a été lancé la date limite du dépôt des
dossiers c'est le 25 juin ça va arriver
vite alors le la représentation en
france de la commission européenne va
identifier puis soutenir des actions
événements qui se déroulent en france et
qui parle de lui
expliquez-nous un peu le concept de ce
programme
alors en fait
il ya beaucoup il ya beaucoup d'acteurs
que ce soit par exemple des ong des
collectivités des établissements et
ainsi de suite qu'ils aimeraient faire
des activités en lien avec l'union
européenne mais pour x ou y raison ça
coûte de l'argent
ça coûte cher par exemple si vous
organisez une conférence faut louer la
salle faut louer les techniciens si vous
pré si vous prévoyez par exemple à
manger après pour les différents invités
et ainsi de suite
si vous faites venir des personnes de
l'extérieur il faut leur payer les
transports ainsi que la chambre d'hôtel
donc tout ça ça coûte de l'argent et
donc l'objectif de la représentation
c'est justement de venir en aide à ces
structures qui souhaitent organiser
justement ces événements pour parler
d'union européenne tout simplement les
soutenant financièrement et en
permettant que ces événements puissent
puisse se dérouler l'an passé déjà
plusieurs lauréats franciliens ont pu
être aidés dans leurs actions et
événements sur l'europe exemple le média
euractiv qui a développé un projet avec
les jeunes regardent et on s'est
installé à pontenx aux médias la 93 qui
est une structure en seine saint denis
qui accueille des projets médias et
culturelles et on va travailler avec eux
pour faire faire des reportages à des
jeunes de seine-saint-denis dans des
lycées dans des structures de retour à
l'emploi est aussi avec des étudiants on
va leur faire faire des reportages sur
ou à l'europe autour de caisse qui ce
qu'est ce qu'ils ont ils d'anti fille de
deux européens comment ils voient leur
pour vous pour essayer de leur montrer
que l'europe c'est un projet qui devrait
les intéresser
olivier j'adore ex concrètement quels
types de projets et actions peuvent être
soutenus et ce que est ce que ces larges
finalement tout événement qui va faire
de la communication institutionnelle sur
l'union européenne peut être concerné
oui c'est très large c'est surtout en
fait le savent être surtout on fait les
caractéristiques de l'événement qui vont
être importantes
on cherche surtout des événements qui
sont pédagogiques donc on est loin par
exemple de formats barbant ou c
on donne des informations aux citoyens
et après c'est le citoyen qui garde pour
lui on cherche surtout des événements
qui sont interactifs où les citoyens
peuvent justement se faire entendre et
faire valoir lors et ils peuvent
justement faire valoir leur opinion
d'accord donc après sur le format de
l'événement on s'est rendu compte que
par rapport aux lauréats de l'année
passée on a tout un tas d'événements on
a tout un tas de formats d'événements
assez variés on a par exemple une série
de on peut avoir des conférences on a
des pièces de théâtre qui ont été
financés on a des émissions de on a des
émissions de télé et de radio avec
parfois le financement d'une émission
complète soit parfois le financement de
petites pastilles ou de chroniques au
sein de l'émission donc c'est assez
c'est assez
l'auteur on peut être financé ça ça
dépend aussi du projet alors ça dépend
du projet il ya 3 il ya trois paliers de
financement il ya un premier palier de
financement à 10000 euros il ya un
deuxième palier de financement à 25000
et il ya un troisième palier de
financement à 45
alors après en fonction du palier de
financement que vous choisissez vous
avez différents objectifs donc par
exemple atteindre tant de personnes pour
tel palier atteindre plus de personnes
pour un autre palier et ainsi de suite
après voilà l'objectif c'est en fonction
du projet qu'on a c'est d'essayer de se
situer par rapport aux meilleurs palier
qui pourrait justement répondre à nos
besoins
dernière minute de cet entretien
justement comment fait-on pour
candidater la date de limite du dépôt
des dossiers c'est le 25 juin alors
voilà la date de dépôt limite c'est le
25 juin alors il y as tout simple c'est
un petit dossier de candidature à
télécharger sur le site de la commission
européenne en france le site s'affiche
d'ailleurs actuellement
donc c'est un petit dossier qui fait une
dizaine de pages qui est assez simple
qui est assez simple
à remplir donc il suffit de télécharger
de leurs voiles à cesser des questions
et on répond aux questions très bien
merci olivier jeanne wake c'est d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle vous
êtes le responsable du centre
d'information europe direct il est situé
à saint germain en laye et pour plus
d'information 1 d'ailleurs un sur ce
centre europe direct vous pouvez aller
sur le site internet qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran attrape la résidence jean
fourcassa fête cette année ses 40 ans
cette maison de retraite non médicalisés
accueille des personnes âgées autonomes
de plus de 60 ans et le personnel ne
ménage pas ses efforts pour prendre soin
des seniors avec de nombreuses activités
et ateliers
reportage de nicolas landry et toki
nirhy lanto ont une très bien les
plantes géographique ou face et
apprendre à cultiver des bonzaïs aux
personnes âgées dans la résidence
fourcassa c'est une des occupations
proposé aux côtés notamment de la
cuisine ou d'ateliers web d initiative
accueillie positivement par les
résidents vous voyez j'ai moi même des
petits bonsaïs que j'avais eue par
monsieur groupe cuillère mais ils sont
deux et à comparer aussi en plus
non mais c'est très intéressant c'est
bien ça fait trois ans que je suis là
youtube vient ici l'autonomie est la
règle
les seniors disposent d'une certaine
liberté ils organisent leurs programmes
comme ils l'entendent
mais quelques services obligatoires leur
sont tout de même fourni le fait qu'on
soit résidence-hôtel me fait que l'on
doit proposer des prestations
obligatoires
c'est à dire que ça permet aux gens
d'être
alors passez aux surveillances mais
disons qu'elles sont dans un milieu
sécurisé 24 heures sur 24
y compris donc les week-ends la
résidence phocas a évolué depuis 1978
aujourd'hui les personnes âgées ont leur
propre appartement
la ménage à leur convenance les
résidents peuvent y recevoir leurs
proches
j'ai ma chance on fait ici la partie la
page sont c'est la partie 1 cuisine
sachant que dans un appartement
moi je ne cuisine pas
l'établissement est géré par
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines il accueille soixante trois
personnes âgées de plus de 60 en un mot
de golf après le numéro un numéro un
mondial par dont justin thomas c'est une
autre star qui foulera et les greens du
golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines pour l'open de france fin juin
il s'agit de l'espagnole céleri au galsi
à vainqueur du masters 100 2017 et de 32
titres sur les circuits mondiaux
il a officialisé sa présence au tournoi
français à quelques mois de la ryder cup
ce sera une grande première pour ce
membre du top 15 mondial
écoutez sa réaction publiée sur les
réseaux sociaux je suis très excité
d'annoncer ma venue au à chennai open de
france à la fin du mois j'ai une chance
de jouer au golf national un parcours
incroyable qui va accueillir la ryder
cup plus tard dans l'année
enfin je ne peux pas attendre de voir
les fabuleux supporters français cette
semaine là et pour la ryder cup
ensemble on va essayer de ramener le
trophée j'ai hâte de vous voir là-bas
prenez soin et ce n'est pas la première
fois que ses trios galsi à jour à un
tournoi en france et dans les yvelines
l'espagnol a participé à cinq reprises
au trophée lancôme entre 1995 et 2002 un
rendez-vous est hébergé par le golf de
saint nom la bretèche
enfin ils sont montés sur scène 27
lycéens de montigny le bretonneux et de
guyancourt ils ont joué à la ferme de
bel ébat taisez vous ou je tire une
pièce de métier nava jo inspiré de la
journée de la jupe est la faim en somme
d'une année de travail pour ces jeux
qui a été présentée mardi mélanie poker
y assister un lycée de banlieue une
professeure sans autorité et une arme
introduites les apprentis comédiens sont
des lycéens saint quentinois il ajouté
vous ou je tire une création de métier
lavage au j'aimais bien que ça parle de
nous dans un des lycéens on est les
premiers touchés parce qu'on est des
élèves on est sensible à tout ça au
début la pièce qu'on semblait très
compliquée et j'avais du mal à j'avais
du mal et faire ce que ça changerait
beaucoup de ce qu'on avait vu dans les
deux précédents projets et me fur et à
mesure enfin on a appris à travailler
ils sont une trentaine à avoir répété
toute l'année en dehors de leur temps
scolaire un travail hebdomadaire pour
les lycées de la roi et des cartes
encadrés par la troupe professionnelle
deutsche bahn groupe lacasse et fort par
elles parlent de leur situation et leurs
préoccupations puisque ça se passe dans
un lycée il ya des difficultés avec une
promettra et puis d'autre part le fait
de jouer avec vilar oacis à leur
apporter beaucoup de choses
[Musique]
c'est essentiel on ne peut pas porter
les mêmes choses
en tant que professeur et en tant que
metteur en scène en tant que comédien
chacun apporte sa pierre et c'est
ensemble qu'on construit quelque chose
et quand on est des professeurs
différents dans des lycées différents on
apporte aussi un regard différent sur
les élèves un travail conclu par une
date unique à la ferme de bel ébat de
guyancourt avant pour certains de
réfléchir à la prochaine création
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce journal ne manquez
pas juste après le 7-8 débat avec un
nouveau présentateur aux commandes
nicolas et kirillovitch belle soirée sur
tv 78
[Musique]